hey everyone in green I'm Jess and this
is house of horrors and weekly show
where we play horror games see you guys
so today we are playing
we're continuing off a series yeah which
we started with yeah we did very very so
today I'll be playing penumbra Requiem
which is the final game in the penumbra
trilogy so this game came out in 2008
yeah is a first-person survival horror
game much in the style over the previous
number game yeah that was unexpected oh
wait a minute what oh good
Oh can we climb No
yeah he's pretty good yeah we can get
slightly shorter
well I look looks like I just made them
oh yeah slightly shorter boxes you made
stairs just say do you see that hey it
looks like Stog a dangerous much weird
portal there's a plank yeah oh my god so
I think if you sit down on another one
we should be able to slide a few over oh
yeah oh my God we're gonna have to put
so many blood it didn't move it a little
so heavy oh oh it's the actual oops oh
I'm so sorry whoever lives in here
yeah oh man well Oh God
Oh get out back back oh well right
I think if you just like push the back
yeah yeah yeah go on
oh yeah
oh no the petals yeah
oh geez oh okay we can see the dead end
up okay oh oh we had to get them out yep
oh yes me down by the godown he just
winged it out no wait that one's like
yep
Oh means we got a gym Oh
soda machine moved that's super-creepy
god the pain
I hate that feeling I know when you just
like their overall under estimating how
unexpected
no cut seems over Danny gravity oh oh we
are supposed to float the look at
varying levels of floating mass yeah no
I didn't then we start on the first
to get the show we're not just gonna
just pick it up
oh my god oh my god all right here we
good why is it spinning I don't know oh
oh my god yes
no I don't know I jump up okay I can't
jump off holding on holding
so go into hell
oh no we got destroy okay let me just if
I throw this box down
precariously
balance it no holding on feels oh my
goodness stuck
which is what I'm here to do now at
least on the side I feel the same way
everything like possibly go wrong I
think I'm going to pieces
oh wait what oh my god oh Jesus
what nothing oh my god are they all up
on their tool
you're right all right let's try Oh God
this is indeed a horrifying us oh my so
that was the number of a crib you can
see we didn't forget I'm quite far
enough
oh I do apologize if that was extremely
frustrating this is how we interact on a
daily anyway anyway I'll put up a
highlight surreal
um joining me was all the boys thanks
everyone
what you thought bye